[Musica]
sono una psicologa e una psicoterapeuta
strategica e mi sono sempre molto
interessata la felicità si può dire che
è stata la motivazione della mia
esistenza è probabilmente la molla per
il mio lavoro
quando avevo 18 12 anni ho deciso che
avrei fatto psicologia e che l'avrei
fatto per aiutare le persone ad essere
felici
pensavo tutti vogliono essere felici
ebbene dopo 20 anni di psicoterapia e
27.000 sedute
ho scoperto molte cose intanto che non è
vero che tutti vogliono essere felici e
poi che non tutti quelli che dicono di
voler essere felici fanno davvero le
cose giuste per riuscirci e quindi
servono delle istruzioni per riuscirci e
per l'abilità alla scienza ce ne ha date
tante di istruzioni perché della
psicologia della della felicità si è
occupata diciamo da secoli la poesia la
filosofia la sociologia la psicologia le
scienze
per esempio sappiamo molte cose sulla
felicità
un contributo importante ce l'ha dato la
psicologia positiva di a martin seligman
che è una marea della psicologia
scientifica che si occupa di capire in
che modo il pensiero positivo influenza
la nostra fisiologia la nostra
psicologia dunque il nostro benessere e
sappiamo molte cose sappiamo per esempio
che una gran parte della felicità
dipende da tre
tra i fattori che hanno sulla nostra
sulla nostra vita
un'incidenza diversa per esempio per il
50 per cento
abbiamo un fattore che è quello della
felicità costituzionale cioè quello che
ci avvertiva in eredità della nostra
famiglia della nostra storia familiare e
pesa il 50 per cento sulla nostra
percezione di felicità
poi abbiamo un altro fattore che incide
per il 10 per cento sulla nostra
felicità e che sono le circostanze della
vita per esempio essere nati in un paese
ricco e democratico è un elemento
positivo per la nostra felicità
poi abbiamo un altro fattore che incide
per il 40 per cento e che quindi è molto
importante e che è sotto il nostro
controllo
cioè legato alle nostre scelte sa se
riusciamo a meno a fare pace con un
passato che ci fa del male a se
riusciamo a costruire relazioni positive
ea stare in contesti positivi se
riusciamo a nutrire pensieri positivi se
riusciamo ad essere ottimisti per
esempio sappiamo che essere ottimisti
riduce i nostri rischi di malattie
cardiovascolari riduce la possibilità di
avere malattie infettive addirittura
riduce il tasso di mortalità eppure
nonostante sappiamo molte cose sappiamo
addirittura cosa succede dal punto di
vista scientifico neuronale ormonale nel
nostro corpo quando proviamo un'emozione
positiva nonostante sappiamo tutte
queste cose
continuiamo a non essere felici allora
cosa serve per la felicità evidentemente
non basta la conoscenza la conoscenza
importante ma non è quella che trasforma
le cose
quello che trasforma le cose è qualcosa
che attraversa le nostre emozioni che ci
passa in modo profondo dentro e che
quindi ci cambia ci aiuta ad avere una
prospettiva differente e per farlo
naturalmente dobbiamo avere un'idea di
che cosa vogliamo
ognuno
di noi per essere felici perché la prima
domanda che dobbiamo farci è che cosa mi
serve in questo momento della mia vita
per sentirmi veramente felice la
felicità non è uno stato permanente non
è una dimensione statica qualcosa di
fuggevole sfuggente come lo sono tutte
le emozioni
quindi abbiamo bisogno di capire che
cosa serve a noi e anche in che modo ci
sentiamo veramente bene con noi stessi
l'idea che essere ricchi e famosi renda
felici tutti è una fantasia un'illusione
ognuno di noi ha la propria felicità e
alla propria felicità di quel momento
quindi dovrebbe chiedersi in quel
momento che cosa gli serve perché deve
imparare anche a realizzare che le cose
che lo rendevano felice un tempo non
necessariamente lo renderanno felice in
quel momento né tantomeno lo renderanno
felice domani o che le cose che rendono
felice lui non necessariamente
renderanno felici qualcun altro ma
soltanto lui dunque un compito che
spetta ad ognuno di noi ma per farlo
dobbiamo innanzitutto crederci dunque
dobbiamo sapere che la felicità è anche
un principio una regola una motivazione
una prospettiva
in sostanza dobbiamo poter credere nella
felicità per sentire la felicità non
basta a desiderarla perché questa
avvenga magicamente ma ci sono anche
molte cose che ci ostacolano nel
raggiungere la felicità per esempio
molte paure
una paura che assilla gli esseri umani e
per esempio quella di deludere le
aspettative degli altri oppure un'altra
importante paura che ci ostacola
pesantemente la paura del giudizio degli
altri di avere un giudizio negativo da
parte degli altri
oppure ancora la difficoltà di
appartenere ad una minoranza perché se
saremo felici saremo sempre meno di
quelli che sono infelici
quindi abbiamo bisogno eventualmente di
un
sento che ci aiuti a superare questi
ostacoli ed andare incontro la felicità
e questo elemento è il coraggio
voi mi direte è un paradosso che
coraggio ci vuole ad essere felici che
ci vorrà mai e poi che tipo di coraggio
serve per essere felici io non vi
risponderò con una definizione per tutto
quello che vi ho detto prima ma voglio
fare con voi un piccolo viaggio voglio
farlo attraverso una storia così da
rappresentarci il senso del coraggio di
cui parliamo stasera c'è un tizio
guardate che bella faccia allegra che
c'è un tizio una persona che ha una
famiglia un lavoro degli interessi e una
passione ama i safari sapete quelli di
caccia grossa in africa ed è proprio in
un safari con il suo gruppo che ad un
hub durante una pausa e rapito da uno
scorcio è meraviglioso e un tramonto
africano si allontana dal suo gruppo si
allontana dal suo autobus dove sono
montate i fucili le munizioni
dove sono i suoi compagni e si va a
godere questo scorcio di tramonto
accanto a questo albero maestoso con gli
occhi persi nell'arancione nel rosso
dell'africa
a un certo punto sente una presenza si
volta e di fronte si trova un leone e
disarmato e atterrito con la coda degli
occhi guarda i compagni che hanno visto
la scena e che stanno cercando di
scaricare le munizioni fucili per
aiutare il compagno
lui no non ha ma questo non vuole essere
visto come un debole non vuole essere
visto come vulnerabile non vuole l'aiuto
degli altri e quindi fa come se di
fronte non avesse un leone come se
quelle non fossero zampe
e fauci e convinto cammina per andare
verso i suoi compagni è risultato nella
storia finisce sbranato
ok riavvolgiamo indietro il nastro
stesso tizio stessa passione stesso
safari stesso tramonto stesso leone e lì
e di fronte al leone e atterrito e
disarmato e terrorizzato con la coda
degli occhi guarda gli amici gli amici
stanno scaricando i fucili le munizioni
vogliono aiutarlo avrebbero potuto
trovarsi nella stessa situazione
lui si rende immobile quasi non respira
per non muovere un muscolo le gambe gli
tremano come foglie e lui cerca di
controllarle davanti ai suoi occhi gli
passa tutta la sua vita i progetti che
realizzato quelli che invece vuole
ancora realizzare alle persone che ama
le persone che ha perso tutto si sente
perduto quando all'improvviso sente un
fragore e un tonfo i suoi compagni hanno
puntato e abbattuto il leone
lui è salvo e può continuare a godersi
il suo safari
ora io vi chiedo chi è per voi quello
coraggioso cos'è il coraggio qualcuno mi
dirà che il coraggio è quella del primo
tizio e quindi l'idea che ha del
coraggio e di una invulnerabilità il
coraggio come assenza di paura il tuo
coraggio come potenza assoluta il pop il
coraggio come chi non accetta di avere
dei limiti affanni cadute il coraggio
come chi crede di non avere bisogno
dell'aiuto di nessuno mai è come finisce
la storia non bene
poi c'è il secondo tizio che tipo di
coraggio mette in atto lui è un coraggio
diverso e il coraggio di chi accetta i
limiti di chi può tollerare l'impotenza
di chi ha la forza di resistere di chi
crede nella possibilità di avere una
chance
chi accetta l'aiuto degli altri quando
evidentemente non può fare diversamente
e resiste e come finisce nella storia si
salva e avrà molte altre opportunità di
essere felice dunque con questo che cosa
ci diciamo
diciamo che il coraggio di essere felice
presuppone l'idea che la felicità non
sia soltanto cose belle che accadono da
sole ma si ha la capacità di superare le
difficoltà di affrontare le cadute di
accettare anche le proprie fragilità e
di andare incontro in modo ottimistico
positivo e superare i problemi e
affrontare i problemi in fondo la
felicità e la capacità di godersi la
fatica nel trovare una soluzione non
soltanto la soluzione ma tutto il
percorso tutto il viaggio non non avere
alcun problema perché questo non è
realistico
la felicità è tutto il processo il
problema e la soluzione la felicità non
è un eden la felicità e la capacità di
godersi tutto lo sforzo e di pensare che
al di là di quella difficoltà c'è un
momento meraviglioso per me nella nostra
vita abbiamo continuamente leoni da
affrontare abbiamo prove importanti a
cui dare delle risposte da cui possiamo
fuggire o che abbiamo possiamo avere il
coraggio di invece di reagire di
affrontare il tipo di lavoro da
scegliere l'uomo con cui passeremo il
resto della nostra vita sulla base di
che tipo di coraggio
noi facciamo queste scelte la felicità
deve essere il clima che diamo alla
nostra esistenza
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]